okay we're in overtime we're in the
we're in the we're in the air we're in
that internet air that's cost 1295 and
these are the questions that have been
sent in
why doesn't education get more attention
from politicians in this country well it
gets a lot of lip service gets plenty of
attention from Chris Christie all of it
negative of course is Chris Christie
pissed me off I'm from New Jersey
I know no I mean the best thing about
Occupy Wall Street is that it's it's
like saying can we stop blaming
everything on the teachers I mean it's
also seriously all all the things were
unwilling or unable to do ourselves we
expect the teachers to do and they fail
you know because they can't be there's
no politician wants to tell the truth
and when the truth is the problem is not
overcrowding the problems not
underfunding the problems not teachers
unions the problems not lack of computer
equipment in each classroom the problem
is your damn kids who's gonna say that
they liked it actually it's actually the
problem is the parents well in fairness
they've done many studies and what they
found is that kids where the parents
read to them and there's books in the
home as opposed to just TV and statues
is anything yes anything were anything
right then without that nothing works
but they ask this is what Chris Christie
you pissed me off because I got a pretty
good public school education in New
Jersey and they asked him like a month
ago what he thought about evolution and
he said none of your business now I can
see saying that in Alabama because I'm
not from Alabama so I can [ __ ] on it but
I'm from New Jersey I you know maybe I'm
trying to be a snob but I think well my
state in Northeast we're a little more
sophisticated we don't we don't talk
that way about evolution but evolution
is none of your business governor fat
fatty
all right was it right for lawrence
O'Donnell to criticize Herman Cain oh I
saw this for not participating in the
civil rights demonstrations while he was
in college no I love lawrence O'Donnell
I love his show I see it every day
but I did I've actually felt bad it was
like when Michael Moore went to Charlton
Heston's house that I felt bad for
Drummond today but no I don't allowance
I love you I don't think he should have
gone after him for he was he was kind of
getting in Herman Cain's grill about not
protesting in the early 60s and and not
going to Vietnam which when her oh gosh
that's terrible I hate people who didn't
go to Vietnam oh yeah well because of
all the bother I had to go to to not go
to Vietnam communist homosexual dope bag
with a bad back people just don't go and
the great thing is you don't have a bad
back anymore yes
[Applause]
I learned comedy it is today I'm telling
to Richard Trumka do you see global
unions as a possibility to combat free
trade agreements well look we have
global organizations right now that are
trying to get together so - we can help
workers on both sides of the border the
idea is to bring up wages so that they
can buy products from us as well as us
buying from them so we're actually
working on that we have one organization
that puts together about a hundred and
forty million workers around the world
working together right now to try to
increase the ability of workers to have
a union a voice on the job once a
right-wing Republican I never thought I
was gonna say this but I came back from
China gone these people need unions I
can't wait till you say it about
Americans but you know what they call
illegal immigrants I kept hearing the
term illegal immigrants in places like
Gwangju you know and Shanghai and so
they mean people from out of town people
fifteen miles from the city who are in
the city working with a legal permit you
know that's that was their illegal
immigrant you know they sort of have a
they call it a union but it's a
appendage of the of the party and but
this year a number of wildcat strikes
took place yeah they were demanding
higher wages at Toyota plants and then
it went a little bit of everywhere and
they didn't know what to do with it
because the official union came back and
said go back to work and they said no we
don't listen to you and they actually
elected their own leaders a democratic
free union movement so I'll be Democrat
got started what about whacking people
do the Union still do that here
you mean with that king we're in a tough
union we're in a tough union I mean you
crossed one of our picket lines will
rule dress up an uncle berry own and
outfit and come over and scare your kids
at the birthday party
mess with after what with Florida and
other states moving up their primary
dates to gain influence wouldn't it be
better and fair to have a national
primary where everybody votes at the
same time I don't know it might be I
think maybe regional primaries you know
where the re one region votes and then
another one maybe you could have a
rotating which would go first
well maybe how about if you wrote you
know one one year it's the Northeast and
one year it's the South because the way
it is now come on I mean you get the
Evangelic olds in Iowa that's basically
who runs the Republican children of the
corn the children of the corn as I
always call them yes
then you go to crusty old grumpy New
Hampshire people like PJ O'Rourke they
vote next and then you go in a bunch of
hayseeds in South Carolina and then it's
all over great system well I I would
worry about putting the candidates
without any money at too much of a
disadvantage so if they've got a
campaign in a whole region having no
money is a real disadvantage Florida it
has nine media markets it's an expensive
state in which to campaign statewide so
I'm not you know weighing in one way or
the other but the smaller states having
their primaries and doing that one at a
time tends to level the playing field
for some of the less funded Canada you
can do the New Hampshire primary
basically with two cases of beer right
a pickup truck I don't think people
realize that Florida has that part that
goes under Alabama
it's almost goes into like Texas yeah
it's you know that part where you
probably are not very popular the
further north you go the further south
you go that's the way it isn't Florida
really yeah but look that the basic
problem is not the order of states the
basic problem is how money saturates the
whole process and I'm sorry but well
good luck with getting rid of that well
we have to find we have to find a way
because it's not gonna happen money is
like water running downhill you can put
whatever you want in its way it'll find
the way around well when corporations
are deciding who is doggcatcher of
podunk Iowa something's gone wrong do
you think you could ever win statewide
election in Florida we'll see really
good what about the no I don't know
anything I I'm running for Congress not
for statewide office all right I wish I
could vote for you thanks folks we gotta
go
[Applause]